here we show that pro cyanide in c1 a
polyphenolic component of grape seed
extract increases the health span and
lifespan of mice through its action on
tunes and cells so hello and welcome to
the chicky science show why yes we are
back with another senescence video as
some interesting research was published
last week regarding the identification
of a news analytic so let's take a look
at the data
now if you've been a viewer with me for
a while then you're a pro at senescence
but just as a brief refresher cellular
senescence as a cell state that a cell
may enter when it undergoes stress that
could be replicative stress from
dividing too many times or too quickly
dna damage oxidative stress and
oncogenic stress
a senescent cell cannot divide and
develops a secretory phenotype known as
the senescence-associated secretory
phenotype the sasp which amongst many
factors includes pro-inflammatory
factors that are thought to drive aging
phenotypes and age-related pathologies
in particular the presence of senescent
cells have been shown to accumulate with
age and have been linked with different
age-associated diseases such as
osteoarthritis neurodegeneration and
lung fibrosis
removing these senescent cells therefore
may help alleviate some of the symptoms
of these diseases
and based on work published in mice it
seems to be the case so far examples
include the combination of the satinabe
even question that delayed
age-associated disorders in mice and is
now in human clinical trials and more
recently facilitating that extended
health and lifespan and mice and
similarly is undergoing human clinical
trials
so there you are we already have
cinelytics that seem promising why are
we still looking well to be frank it's
not known exactly how these drugs
specifically kill senescent cells and
what impacts they still have on healthy
cells
moreover senescent cells are very
heterogeneous and some synthetics may
only remove a subset of them and not all
of them or they might remove all of them
and maybe we only want to remove a
certain subset of them
others analytics if identified could be
more effective work at a lower dose have
fewer side effects these sorts of things
so yeah they're still interested in
trying to identify synalytics
so this nicely leads on to this recent
publication the flavonoids pro cyanide
in c1 has stenotherapeutic activity and
increases lifespan and mice
so the first thing they did in this
paper was through an infantry screen so
in petri dishes to test the effects of a
medicinal library of natural products on
control so healthy cells and senescent
cells
they tested their model first by using
known cenolitics and as you can see and
apologize the resolution is not amazing
but in grey you have control growing
cells representing healthy cells
and red bars show you the number of
senescent cells
so what this graph is showing is that
when you add
abt263 or ab2737
or the combination of the satellite and
quercetin so known as analytics the
number of senescent cells decrease
because they've died
so they then used the same model and
tested the other compounds in their
library and as you can see here they
identified five that seem to be working
as semilytics
you have fissitin which is kind of
already known to work quercetin curcumin
pipalongamine and grapeseed extract
since it remains largely unexplored the
authors decided to focus on grape seed
extracts
at higher concentrations it showed
greater sonogenetic potential but it
plateaued at 3.75 micrograms per
milliliter
importantly though even at
concentrations of 15 micrograms per
milliliter it didn't seem to affect the
viability of healthy growing cells
so this fulfills the criteria of a
synolytic agent
the thing is grape seed extract is
evidently a mixed bag of molecules so
what exactly is it that's mediating
these benefits
well they did some mass spectrometry to
see what compounds are found in grape
seed extract and it includes a
combination of phenolic acids and
flavonoids as well as protein iodine
and to cut a long story short it turned
out to be the molecule pro cyanide in c1
pcc bond that was possessing their
cenolitic potential
it was only at higher concentrations
that it caused these senescent cells to
die
but this is all nice so far
but it's just been done in cell culture
dishes
what about some in-fivo data
well they tested pcc one in mice they
did a few different things but i'll only
show you a couple of examples here one
experiment they did was treat aged mice
here 20 months of age with pcc one once
every two weeks for four months
so similarly to other studies they're
adopting this hit and run strategy for
cenolytics the idea that once you clear
the senescent cells it takes a bit of
time for them to re-accumulate and so if
you can use them only intermittently it
might help to reduce side effects
and a bit of a tangent but there's been
some hate for these mouse diagrams
i mean personally i think they look a
little bit more like rabbits but i do
like the whiskers
anyway pcc one refers senescence
associated beta gal activity so this is
just a marker that we commonly use to
identify senescence cells
refers to staining in kidney liver lung
and prostate as well as showing
functional improvements in maximal
walking speeds grip strength and
treadmill endurance
they then did a separate study where
they gave pcc one once every two weeks
starting at an even older age this time
24 to 27 months old mice so this equates
to around 75 to 90 year old humans
anterior showed a 9.4 percent longer
overall lifespan and a 64.2 longer
median lifespan
suggesting that pcc one decreases the
risk of age-associated mortality
so as a quote from the article we hereby
present proof of principle evidence that
even when administered in late life such
a therapeutic modality holds prominent
potential to remarkably delay
age-related dysfunction reduce
age-related diseases and enhance health
conditions thus providing a new avenue
to improve health span and lifespan in
future geriatric medicine
so what are my thoughts well i mean so
far it looks pretty promising especially
with the impact by giving it to the mice
at late life but for me there are two
main questions that remain
firstly how translatable will it be to
humans so obviously we won't know this
data until randomized control clinical
trials have been performed
and secondly the biochemistry wants to
know why and how this is happening what
is pcc one targeting and how can we use
that knowledge to further understand the
analytics how they're functioning or
maybe to identify better alternatives
they did show in a study that pcc one
seems to be somehow inducing
mitochondrial dysfunction by
paradoxically increasing the levels of
reactive oxygen species
which they did show in the study that
when it combined pcc one with a
resveratrol analog that suppresses the
reactive oxygen species the cenolitic
activity was also reduced and so this
actually raises an interesting question
that they don't really talk about about
what would happen if you combined this
pcc one with other potential anti-aging
compounds so again this is why it's so
important to understand how these agents
are supposedly acting within a cell and
so probably for your interest where can
we actually find pcc one well as evident
from this paper you can seem to find it
in grape seed extract but there's lower
abundance as well in extracts of
cinnamon apple peels and pine bark
so all in all to quote again from this
article
pcc one represents a new class of
phytochemicals analytics isolated from
natural sources that delay aging and
ameliorate age-related disorders and
warrants further exploration as a
potential geru-protective agent in
clinical medicine
so with that i hope you've enjoyed this
great video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you